we got a lot of single people on my team
and is there any strategies you want to
share with the rest of us that worked
for you so I'll give you two two
strategies
here's what I'll tell you one is if
you're by yourself and you're going to a
nightclub and the other one is who you
were going to the nightclub it's very
very important what crew you go out with
okay so let's first focus on you then
we'll give the crew if it's you okay if
it's you and you're going by yourself to
a nightclub or a place that's gonna have
a lot of options there make one round
and on your one round compliment twenty
different women in areas that they put a
lot of time into so complimenting them
on what everyone's gonna say oh my gosh
you know you got such a you know I love
your body I love you but all these that
deadlines not effective got it maybe for
a certain community but not effective
for all communities and it's been tested
by the way many many times but you're
telling a compliment on hair cuz I took
time to fix my hair I love your eyebrows
because eyebrows you got to put details
into it hey I gotta tell you I'm big on
you the right amount of makeup I can
tell you did the right amount of makeup
your face you look very very good it's
got to be things that they're putting
time into your toes flawless I got to
have little your toes are flawless those
things stick around so when you count
the second round and you're coming back
now you got one by the way you
compliment and you move on on the second
round you get a smile then when you get
the smile you say can I get you a drink
if she's by herself you get her a drink
there's 19 other girls that are looking
at you saying nobody complimented them
on that specific area so this part it's
pretty proven this is gonna help any
single guide if we can get to do this
you'll have a good tip you look forward
to going to nightclubs the other part is
if you got a crew this part with the
crew is a complete different game plan
when you have a crew I'm working for you
so for instance I'm not flirting I'm
flirting for you I'm not flirting for me
so we'd go to club and you know you
would say I'd say hey
would it regrows here you like and you'd
say the girl in the green said who else
that one over there okay Ulster okay let
me get to work so then I'm going and my
language is very easy because my
language is gonna be hey look I gotta
tell you I'm good I got a girl but my
buddy here who's standing right over
there thinks you're hot cat bit his
tongue you know he kind of wants to get
to know you I've been telling him go but
he can't you know he's trying to face
his fears and would you mind if you and
I go together with them and if I can
make the introduction would that be okay
with you even if it's just a
conversation oh yeah okay one out of
three times
it worked mm-hmm so and I didn't get
rejected right so I go there I make the
pitch I come back I make the
presentation I make the connection then
it's on you on what you're gonna do with
the words because now it's fully on you
to be able to you know build the
conversation and get him going but those
two strategies if I tell you if you were
part of my crew you're gonna have a good
time that's all I can tell you you had a
great time and and by the way there's a
proven record of this people I had
friends from high school who would fly
into the military just to come and spend
a week with me they all went back wanted
to come back to the military because we
did this in a very effective fashion I'm
sure you made a lot of single guys happy
with that strategy good luck to you
[Music]